hi this is christine pascoe
and i'm going to be talking about
considerations in selecting a limbs for
the cannabis testing laboratory
today i've been working in limbs and
laboratory automation
for over 20 years and really enjoy
getting laboratories automated
and eliminating many of the mundane
tasks so that they can be competitive
today we're going to look at some of the
regulatory pressures and business
pressures that laboratories are facing
along with some technologies that help
alleviate some of these pressures in
terms of
managing all of the laboratory data that
laboratories are responsible and
required to manage
in today's environment and then also
some tools that help them
to become more efficient and effective
as well as more productive
let's look at today's agenda we're going
to be looking at
what limbs what is a limbs
why are they important considerations in
selecting a limbs
as well as technical considerations
looking at the return on investment cost
of ownership
keeping in mind regulatory compliance
goals as well as iso 17025
gmp good manufacturing practices fda and
others
as well as metric integration and then
looking at some of the common features
that help laboratories become automated
and then finally instrument integration
which is a significant time saver
as well as reporting and automated
reporting
and also leveraging mobile technology so
this is on
tablets in the field to collect data and
automatically upload that to the lens
followed by a quick summary
a few of the learning objectives for
today's presentation
include key requirements to examine
in selecting a lens including the vendor
the type of support the technology
the long-term strategy of that
organization
in terms of technology and also looking
at the role that the lims plays
in providing the laboratory automation
improvements
increasing the efficiency shortening the
turnaround times enhancing their data
quality
while maintaining regulatory compliance
and understanding
integration benefits and this isn't just
instrument integration this can also be
integration with
enterprise applications such as sap
crm as well as some regulatory
integration such as metric and then
understanding the impact of automation
on the laboratory operations
from leveraging positive id so this is
bar coding one-dimensional
two-dimensional
as well as rfid and also automated
reporting
and that can be electronic reporting as
well as
providing paper or pdf reports to
clients
now if we take a step back and ask what
is a lens a lims
is a laboratory information management
system it's typically software though
they're all paper-based systems but
they're not as efficient
they manage all of the information
samples test results
and really everything in the laboratory
that goes into the testing
so it includes chemicals reagents
supplies expiration dates of those
lot numbers vendor information
employee training instrument maintenance
calibration
repair records everything that's
required to facilitate regulatory
compliance to the iso 17025 standard
if we look at lens functionality it
begins with
the limbs as the central database where
everything is stored
the limbs basically allows laboratories
to track samples as they're logged into
the laboratory
from sample prep through final
disposition and disposal
it allows result entry via off the
instrument
or manual quality assurance and quality
control
and this includes qc charts trending
leveraging tablets for bench work where
there may not be the room for a pc
or field work if someone is in a field
where they need to collect samples and
log the gis coordinates of that field
and maybe take some readings in the
field some you know soil
test or ph test and then uploading that
information to the limbs
and then finally reporting because if
you work in the lab
your final output is data it's a report
it's not
a widget it's the data and the clear and
more effective that data can be
presented the more successful the
laboratory will be
and some laboratories perform perform
stability testing
so basically if they have added a
compound to a food product they want to
see how long is that food product stable
the limbs can help in this scenario by
allowing
sample scheduling to be pre-logged into
the limbs and reminders sent out so that
analysts know when they need to pull a
sample for testing
and then we previously talked about
chemical inventory
as well as resource management having
web portals where customers have the
ability to
um access their data 24 7
integration with metric which is for
regulatory compliance
having electronic notebooks also be able
to
export data into the lens so that the
lens is basically
the master database where all the
information is housed
all right why are limbs critical well
the first thing is they can really
reduce
data entry errors i've been in
laboratories that don't have limbs
and frequently they're doing data entry
multiple times
that's not efficient and it's also very
error prone especially from a
transcription error standpoint
increasing automation
increases traceability you can see who
did what when
there's an audit trail for any changes
to validated and approved results along
with a reason
so if a result is changed an auditor
wants to understand why was that change
made
and again what was the reason and what
was the original result and who entered
the original
result and they also like to see the
date and time stamps
within a limbs you can actually assign
privileges and permissions
such that different people in the
laboratory will have privileges to
different
functions and features in the limbs and
with those functions and features
they'll have different permissions
and then finally you'll have an
electronic tool to manage
all aspects of laboratory information
now there are many new cannabis testing
laboratories that are being constructed
if we look at what is required the first
thing is
to obtain a new building or facility or
secure one that's already in place
hire and train qualified scientists
chemist
microbiologists that are very well
versed in the
requirements of the international
standard organization 17025 which
pertains to laboratories
being able to purchase and validate
instruments a number of different
vendors that supplies
similar instruments so being able to do
your due diligence
to determine which instrument best meets
your needs
and also to develop and validate methods
author sops standard operating
procedures
and train staff on them one of the other
benefits of
limbs is that you actually have the
ability to link your sop
onto the limbs so that if a user
logs in with their username and password
and pulls up a test they actually can
see work instructions or sops
for that specific test users also need
to be trained on metric and they need to
receive their metric api keys before our
api licenses before they can even begin
to use metric
they have to develop a state approved
certificate of analysis report
and then submit all that information to
the state for approval and licensing
whether it's from medicinal or
recreational before they can even begin
testing any product in their laboratory
and then also scheduling and passing
their iso 17025 audit
now if we look at some of the market
drivers for limbs
we can see it's basically to have secure
data management
as well as securely manage
that product throughout the laboratory
so if you have a kilo of cannabis
and you use a portion of that for
testing
regulators want to understand where the
rest of that's being stored how much is
being used
how much is used up how much is left on
hand and how much is ready for
disposal so it's very important to have
that traceability or internal chain of
custody
with with the laboratory's limb system
so not only do you have increased
efficiency and data security but you
also have standardization
in that you have assurance that everyone
using your system
is following the same sops has the same
setup and this is especially true
true when you have multiple laboratory
sites and we're seeing that more and
more where clients will have
operations in north america as well as
south america europe
and asia so it's very important to have
standardization in business
we've previously touched on regulatory
compliance
you know whether laboratories are doing
cannabis growing
whether they're doing final product
testing whether they're involved with
food manufacturing and testing
additives in food there's different
regulations that come into play
so it's important to understand what
you're planning on doing and what
regulations will cover your scope of
work
limbs provide organizations with a
strong competitive advantage
and also it helps communication across
the organization
i know when i worked in the laboratory
people were always you know looking for
samples and
again again it's not foolproof samples
need to put
be put into the limbs to be able to find
them but being able to look up
test results without having to find the
person that ran the test is just
it's a huge advantage and then finally
we touched on globalization imperatives
lens is really a mission critical tool
for the laboratory
everything from the minute the samples
hit the door
sample tracking chain of custody and
inventory control
it was the internal chain of custody
from data entry and reporting
creating qc batches qaqc work list
looking at trends instrument integration
i know we've got a library of over 550
different instruments that we've
interfaced already
looking at shelf life studies or
stability studies chemical inventory
proficiency testing these are tests that
the state or whoever your regulating
body
is typically they send laboratory blind
samples and they ask you to analyze them
because they've tested them and there's
a known amount of
compound in there and they want to see
if you also
are able to get the results similar to
theirs
employee training is also tracked under
iso
and they're also looking at in the
training records having tests to
prove that the training was effective
documenting
instrument maintenance repair as well as
calibrations
noting when calibrations are next due
not allowing
testing to be done on an instrument
that's out of calibration
also looking at things such as
preventive and corrected corrective and
preventative actions kappas
the crm module allows clients to keep
track of any complaints against the
laboratory
if any testing was complete and perhaps
a report was missing
a page was missing from a final report
sent to a client
those all need to be tracked analyzed
and
remediated and then finally reporting
reporting to metric reporting to clients
reporting
invoices and then having internal
reports such as work list reports or
management reports backlog production
and then finally electronic data
exchange where you may be working with
other organizations that want to import
those results
into their system we talked a little bit
about metric it's basically a regulatory
compliance system
built by regulators for oversight and it
provides
necessary visibility for adherence to
the rules regulations and statuses
it's both it has both an industry side
as well as a regulatory side
the industry side is used to report
required events and information
while the regulatory side is used for
enforcement and compliance monitoring
so that is something very important for
many states
now we talked about production through
analysis
many laboratories focus on one type of
testing whether it's just a cut like
contract commercial testing where they
receive product
be it you know food products for testing
or
raw material maybe it's just
the powder or the leaves or the plant so
depending on what is received to the
laboratory they'll have to do sample
prep
and then analyze it whatever product
they receive
so keep in mind that some organizations
will have
operations where it's kind of like farm
to final product well they'll grow it
they'll purify it
and then they'll convert it to the final
product whether it be in
medicinals or lotions or
even edibles so there's always testing
it every step
every step of the way people always ask
well what do cannabis laboratories
actually test for well they test for
quite a bit
just high level overview they test for
pesticides
mycotoxins they test for bacteria such
as e coli
because the last thing you want to do in
a dispensary where you're providing
medicinal cannabis is get
someone ill from a contaminant in the
product they also test for potency
as well as solvents checking to see if
any foreign material
is in the product any heavy metals
water activity that impacts the shelf
life so there's quite a bit of testing
that's done
navigating the lens market so looking at
a lens market
it's really important to understand the
different technologies
there's some software packages that use
much older language
there's some that use newer or open
source and there's pros and cons to each
so it's important
to understand the language that the
software that you're
considering was written in understanding
if they
perhaps only have a cloud delivery as
software as a service
or if it's something that you can buy
and install on your premise
when it's software as a service you're
basically leasing it
when it's a premise software you
typically purchase it see a lot of
software companies moving to the cloud
as a kind of lease service you want to
also look
at the reporting tools used because
remember if you're in the laboratory
your final product is a report and you
want to make sure that the reporting
tools are flexible and easy to use
and then you also want to look at the
solution and see if it's configurable
because it's much easier to configure a
solution with the tools that are
provided by the vendor
than to customize if you customize
software
you can actually customize yourself
into software that can never be upgraded
and that's something that you want to
avoid
so remember configuration is always
better over customization
the only things that should ever be
customized are reports because they'll
be unique to your laboratory
and instrument integration because every
instrument has a unique output file
and then also look at the vendor support
hours is the support in
outside of the country or is it inside
the country is it the hours that your
laboratory
does business and and also what services
are offered
um ensuring that the system is future
proof basically just means that
if you add anything to the software or
if you configure anything
you're not preventing yourself from
getting a future update
and one of the most important factors i
believe is the ease of use the usability
is the software easy to navigate or is
it a
really confusing and very difficult to
learn
so all these factors go into
understanding the return on investment
how quickly can you deploy the software
and how quickly can users begin to use
it and see the benefits
this slide i realize has a lot of
information on it but
basically it's just showing that you can
have
dashboards you can barcode scanning or
rfid
you can have manual data entry you can
print out reports manually
you can do scheduling you can generate
um chain of
chain of custodies as well as
certificate of analysis
um the scheduling can also be used for
stability studies
and then you can have instrument
integration and you can have automated
backups and then in the cloud you can
actually have clients that
use a web portal to check on the status
of their test results
and if the testing has been complete
they actually have the ability to
download
the test results and download a pdf of
the final report maybe it's a c of a or
it's a final analysis report or even an
invoice
and then also the ability to use tablets
in the field
where it leverages wi-fi 4g or 5g
and then you can basically upload the
gps data the gis coordinates to the
limbs along with any test results that
you have
so it's really looking at the total
solution
now if we look at this total solution
again it can actually
be deployed on premise or via the web so
if we look at you know
premise based solutions there's a number
of pros and cons to each
and you know one of the major pros is
that
the users are close to their data you
don't have to pay
the monthly service charges because all
of your costs are up front
so that can be a con because it's a
large capital outlay
initially whereas software as a service
you know if you don't have the resources
to
have a full-time i.t staff
to manage the software the servers the
the network the firewalls you don't have
to
have that investment all at once you can
just have a monthly fee
i mean i'm not going to read all of the
pros and cons but i just wanted to
present that
there's advantages and disadvantages to
each and
it really depends on your own situation
as to which is going to work
best for your laboratory
looking at sample tracking and inventory
control
it's very important especially for high
throughput laboratories
to move samples through the laboratory
very quickly and login is oftentimes
login and reporting are two bottlenecks
that people face
so looking at bench sheets they can be
barcoded to quickly
log in samples the internal chain of
custody can
be moved along by just scanning samples
barcodes and scanners rfid they're all
very efficient very quick very accurate
and they just make sense in making sure
that you have
tight control over the samples that are
entering your laboratory
and leaving them because you can scan
them out for disposal
key features and the internal chain of
custody for a lens
a controlled substance sample inventory
laboratories control
the test control substances have to have
this internal chain of custody
they want to manage the transaction the
quantity the units
who performed the login
who performed the prep who performed the
analysis
when they were disposed how much was
disposed any comments
inventory by location by type and how
much time they spent in storage
so again it's all about control an
integrated sample inventory workflow
with the ability to manage the required
controlled substances
is critical to cannabis labs and
many many labs leverage limbs to make
sure that they have this control in
place and this is one of the things that
the auditors look at as well
more and more laboratories rely on kpis
or key performance indicators
and having a dashboard at their
fingertip
is very helpful in terms of you know how
many tests are in-house currently
how many tests are on the backlog report
what's our largest test
what's our cost per test you can monitor
your fridges and your
refrigerators your freezers your
incubators there's just so many
things that you can monitor in real time
all in one spot that makes the
laboratory more effective
next we'll look at data entry and
reporting
and here you can see that batch order
login being able to log in a large
number of samples at once is very
effective
rapid and sessioning we already talked
about leveraging barcoding for that or
rfid
having reports automatically printed
such as your certificate
of analysis or your invoice report they
can be sent
to the web portal for clients to access
24 7
and the beauty is that clients use their
time their resources so that the
laboratory can focus on
more more analysis and doing more work
we briefly touched on instrument
integration earlier and this is just a
huge advantage for laboratories
not only does it increase the accuracy
of the data but it also avoids duplicate
data entry
it enhances your productivity
laboratories typically
achieve their return on investment
within a year but it's probably closer
to nine months it's based
completely on your sample volume i've
seen roi's as
quick as two to three months so again
it's really based on your throughput
look at how many instruments the vendor
has experience integrating because this
is really a significant part of any lens
deployment is the integration with not
just instruments
but also other enterprise applications
now if we look at how instrument
integration works
instruments typically export their
results in a number of different formats
whether it's a csv an excel text ascii
xml a web service
or if you just want to export from date
one database to the
another database and they can also
import contract lab data so that
everything is going into the limbs
some instruments some of the more modern
instruments allow a work list to be sent
from the limbs
to the instrument the instrument will
run all the samples
and then send that completed work list
back to the limbs
and the beauty is it's very fast it's
very accurate
and there's no human involvement other
than loading the samples on the on the
tray
and then there's an error log if
anything wasn't imported
correctly that you can view but it's
quick
quick and easy with leveraging barcodes
and instrument integration in terms of
saving time
and becoming more efficient
okay qc qaqc and trending
you can actually set up data qualifiers
in the limbs as well as limits so that
if any result
falls outside the limits it can be
automatically
highlighted on screen the minute the
data is coming off the instrument or the
minute the analyst is entered in a
result
you can view the data with qc charts you
can also do
statistical process control charts we
have integration with
jmp software from sas so you can look at
some
very interesting trends and data that
may not be apparent
otherwise being able to report
as we mentioned previously is huge in
laboratories that do cannabis testing
because this is their final product
so having canned reports already
complete in the system that they can
basically add their logo to and use
right out of the box will save the
laboratory a lot of time
and resources you can also digitize
signatures and link that to a user's
username and password so once the
supervisor has validated and approved
the results
they can automatically print out the
report and email it to
one of their clients another really nice
feature
is a web portal that links to the lims
that allows
external customers access to the data in
real time so 24 7 they can log on
they can print out a c of a it's a pdf
they can look at electronic data
deliverables edds
they can look at invoices any images
that you're interested in having
attached so there's a lot of
power and flexibility in having that
data available
we talked a little bit about tablets
having tablets in the field so that you
can basically
document the sampling site by the gis
coordinates
that really reduces the amount of paper
or the carbon footprint
and it just also is significant in
reduction of cost because
if paper forms are used in the field
those typically have to be brought back
into the laboratory
and transcribed into some electronic
format so having that
mobile technology be a window into the
limbs really helps to reduce
transcription errors as well as
paperwork
at the end of the day it's really about
standardization quality data
efficiency traceability having
regulatory compliance
to make laboratories bulletproof for
their iso 17025 audits
speed metrics reliability repeatability
visibility being able to share
information with others in your
organization
and working more intelligently because
the people that
are working in the cannabis testing labs
they're only they're all highly educated
scientists chemists microbiologists
and the more you can eliminate the
mundane task from their workload
the more effective they can be in terms
of growing the business and focusing on
the chemistry
a few benefits of automation simplifying
the report generation because it's
automated with templates
ensuring regulatory compliance allowing
analysts to have work list
and scheduling for stability studies
instrument calibration can be tracked as
well as employ certifications and
trainings
instrument interfaces accelerate data
results delivery to the final customer
you can have better control over your
inventory as well as your
employee training and kappa management
better customer service because you can
become more efficient
have better quality control on your
internal data
you have access to advanced analytics
and tracking with qaqc
the electronic chain of custody saves
paper and time
and then also being able to send
automated email alerts
and have all the data in the data
warehouse so within the
web portal you have an exact copy of
every report that was sent to any client
so that you always have that readily
accessible
summary the right lens is critical for
today's state-of-the-art cannabis
testing laboratory
making sure that you have the right
tools and leveraging the best technology
that includes positive id
sophisticated limbs that are extremely
powerful and helping manage
and grow businesses many also have
integration with your accounting package
so that
you can be assured that everything
that's logged in will be billed
understanding the differences in the
pros and cons between premise and cloud
eliminating all the mundane tasks label
creation
instrument integration like if you
didn't have the instruments interface
someone would have to basically enter
the results by hand
so having that all electronic is a huge
time saving
as well as automating the electronic
reporting
to metric and other agencies
and then it basically also accelerates
communication across your organization
such that
if you need to share data with others
you can basically
send people copies of the data they can
actually access the system and also see
where samples are within the system
the roi is very quick for for
laboratories typically under a year
and then also you're facilitating your
regulatory compliance
windows authentication is also important
cfr 21 part 11 compliance
being able to have things like
temperature monitoring monitoring
integrated in your limbs so
instead of having each refrigerator and
freezer incubator monitored manually
every day
you can secure a product that will
monitor that
24 7 and have that data be linked in the
limbs or displayed in the limbs as well
and then making sure that you have a
very strong
internal chain of custody and audit
trail for
for your auditors and also for your
internal team members
if anyone's interested in additional
information there's a paper that was
published last year in american
laboratory we'll be happy to send that
and with that i'd like to thank everyone
for their time and attention today
have a great day